good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
and happy friday
friday gotta get down on friday
it is true the rumors are true we made
it to friday
pat yourselves on the back you did it
we're so
proud of you and it's just beautiful
it's a beautiful day
the rumors are true i deleted my twitter
um yeah it's friday like can you believe
it i can't believe it i was just
snapping along and
just reminding myself of my middle
finger pain which i still have
someone reached out to me told me that
it is a nerve pain and that i need to do
some
physical therapy and that's just a lie
no it's not
it's did you even try the splint like
the most basic thing no i didn't do a
slinty vibe yet
sleep with it in a splint for one night
and i promise you like your life will be
changed okay
i mean i before you go down the route of
like nerve endings okay but i also feel
like
at the wellness retreat like they
definitely have like a physical
therapist and like i might actually get
some physical therapy you know
i don't know if i would assume that the
wellness retreat has a physical
therapist i think the wellness retreat
has everything and also it's not i feel
like one mr treat is a little misleading
because like
wellness retreat sounds to me like yoga
reiki right
healing crystals no it's not it this is
a fitness retreat
oh my that sounds like torture
um you guys this is the last day you're
gonna see me before i go on my retreat
vr of wellness and fitness before
retreating before retreat so take a good
look at me now
take a look at me now i actually might
look well
such a good song what song is that it's
just here
to remind me just the memory of your
face
so take a look at me now i don't know
against all odds phil collins and that's
what
gavin the girl against
wait hold on it's literally phil collins
it's literally mr degraw
against all odds hold on
a face gavin negra covers it though okay
it is against all odds by phil collins
and gavin degraw no again i i can hear
it in my
maybe he covers it that's what i'm
saying and that's
the better version gavin degraw well i
know the original i'm actually a big
phil collins
it's not coming up oh yeah no you're
right az lyrics gavin degraw against all
odds
great so take a look at me now yeah i
guess he did a cover but
it's remarkable you know what i've
learned in my old age is that like i'm a
big phil collins girl
you are colors is such a good song no
and like then you're such an emily
emma like lucy pot wha what's her name
emily in paris is
phil collins daughter what's her name
lily collins lily
i was thinking like emily collins
doesn't sound right
no she that's like the type of nephews
i'm like i fully support you know
yeah um what i was gonna say is even
though i'm br i might look well today
because
i drank an entire gallon of water
yesterday i saw you at a new water
bottle i got a new water bottle
i was influenced by olivia culpo she
showed this water bottle that like
gives you all these benchmarks to drink
a gallon of water each day
and i got the water bottle and it is
massive how many times did you pay
i peed a lot but because like they give
you a or 7 am 9 a.m like i really tried
to like be on schedule
and that did split up the keys quite
evenly and it wasn't like
ruining my day how many times i had to
pee but you know what did make my day
aside from being a hydrated queen
i made a chili so did i and i think it's
a tale of two chilies because
chile made your day mine ruined mine my
chili was so wonderful so i had
ground turkey in the fridge that was
like on its last day like needed to cook
tonight
so i followed a half-baked harvest
recipe white bean and turkey chili
i cooked it on the stove even though she
calls for a slow cooker like i'm sorry i
don't have one and i also don't have an
instant pot so i just like
modified the instagram did you use your
lecture set no
my legroom set is like in storage and so
i just used um
you got to get your legroom set out of
storage i know i just use a pot on the
stove
i use my liquid set i mean so here's
what happens you're not one to talk
anyways i just want to say like five
stars one of the best chilies i've ever
made
way better than my vegetarian chili zach
loved it like it's hard
as long as you have like a decent chili
once you put the sour cream and cheese
on top if you're into that and avocado
anything can be a delicious chili really
so there's a lot of room for error
but this was just a fantastic chili
thank you for the recommendation
it was it was a bright spot for me mine
was just like
not for me a full day of like torture
like
okay so the second we i decided to make
a chili i ordered from the butcher
and i got like the four through eight
window and of course it came at eight
like why couldn't have come at four
and so it was just like all day waiting
around for me and then i like got all
the ingredients i got the beans and the
canned tomatoes
and then by the time like all the stuff
was actually at my house it was already
eight o'clock and i was so [ __ ]
hungry
so it wasn't in the mood to like a good
chili needs to sit it needs to
marinate so i just like made it really
half fast and then like
the second all this [ __ ] was in the bowl
i like stirred it and ate it even though
like that those canned tomatoes like
need time to like
soak up the juice of the onions how long
do you leave it in all the [ __ ] in the
bowl you need at least
20 i did 20 minutes it needed more okay
it needed more and so it was fine and me
and ben were like it's fine ben was
being nice it just like wasn't great and
then my stomach started to hurt i'm like
did i just give myself diarrhea
so it was like a whole journey and what
do you think it was maybe you had like
raw meat i got it fresh from the butcher
no no but like
maybe the meat no no no no no no uh the
cook the meat was fully browned before i
even added like the tomatoes and stuff
okay maybe you got like that's like my
biggest phobia maybe you got a little
like meat
salmonella juice on your hand or
something
but the meat was fresh so no but like
raw meat can
carry no i just think like i ate a lot
of something that like wasn't that good
so like i shouldn't have eaten it
you know okay exactly if i were to
simplify it it was just like a whole
day's journey
and then i was like why did i even sign
up for this stupid [ __ ] activity
i mean i'm i hate to hear that because
it was it was such a bright spot
and that's why i just should like let
ben do it but he didn't get home till
seven and i was like really hungry
didn't get there too late no sorry he
didn't get home till eight so like he
was leaving as a phone as a food arrived
so i'm like let me just get started
and then like i who am i kidding you
know yeah
[ __ ] am i kidding but now i have chili
for days in my fridge so i'll be having
chili for lunch chili for dinner
chili until i go to my retreat oh my god
do you think they have chili at the
retreat
chili is it could be a healthy delicacy
so it's possible
but i'm not gonna eat meat so
everything's gotta be veg for your girl
so this is basically your send-off we're
so excited for you
we are really wishing you the best we
will keep you in our thoughts
um monday through wednesday of next week
ben and i will be hosting here at the
studio so make sure to tune in for that
and then thursday friday of next week
there are no episodes because me and ben
will be traveling
but um i think we should just like get
this send-off
kicked off okay i mean i'm going to miss
everyone i want to thank you all
for you're going to miss everyone it's
like cam thank you all for your support
like i hope that when i come back i have
like
stories and joy dave and so much to
share and like insights maybe some
takeaways that i can
relate to the group at large um i'm a
little nervous
because it's like first day it's
literally first day of camp and like you
have to make friends
make friends exactly it's gonna be like
a lot of i think time alone so if you
have any great book recommendations send
them my way
jackie will of course be vlogging the
entire experience for our patreon
channel so head over to patreon.com
morning toast
yeah so i don't know you know what sort
of journey the video is going to take me
on like is it going to be
uplifting is it going to get is it going
to get sad and dark is it going to be
like you regret like the second you get
there
like right it is a possibility we just
have to put that out on the table it is
a possibility
and but i don't think so you're i don't
want to say where you are but like
you're going to be somewhere fabulous
like how bad could it be
yeah truly how bad could it be and also
i'm just gonna have it's only seven days
like even if it's not what i wanted it
to be like i'm gonna stick it out i'm
gonna is there any chance you go home
early
it would have to be like really bad like
unsafe
yeah you know okay so keep us updated
please we shall see just want to thank
you all once again like for your belief
in your girl
and for encouraging me to follow my
dreams no and that's
that's like what we're constantly
preaching here at the morning toast if
there's something you want to do
there's an itch you have scratch it and
that's what you [ __ ] did and you're
an inspiration to women everywhere
thank you scratching your own itches
thank you guys so much i hope this is
the start of a
of a beautiful journey and and you know
what it is it's the start of something
new
and turning things around you know we've
got to turn the beer around
left to hit percussion
i actually need to go shopping today and
like get fitness clothes
etc so that's like not a fun activity
but maybe i can make it fun
well i'm headed to bucks county me and
margo and ben are spending the weekend
with tpga and honestly i'm a little
upset because i want a tbg on myself but
he insisted i bring my husband and my
sister
so um i'll just have to like corner him
for some special alone time yeah you'll
have to like lock snitch and then in a
room
throw away the key like put like a
sleeping pill in their drinks so like
they sleep all day and i'm like oh they
must be so tired
brian want to go for a drive stop
okay well i guess without further ado to
do
here are the fast five stories you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast
and i'm excited to dive in and i'm
excited to let everyone know that
today's episode is brought to you
by martha stewart and marley spoon the
meal kit delivering
a curated variety of chef design recipes
by america's most trusted home chef
martha stewart martha stewart and marley
spoon make great tasting meals possible
every day of the week
by delivering a variety of recipe
options ranging from breakfast to dinner
to desserts
meals feature both the classic flavors
you love plus new and exciting flavors
you'll want to discover
they have a new menu of 29 deliciously
different recipes every week
all the recipes can have six simple
steps and 10 ingredients and they can be
prepared in just about 30 minutes
ordering is super easy and it removes
the burden of grocery shopping and meal
planning
so when it comes to meal kits
if you're gonna get one like why not the
one that was literally made by martha
stewart we all aim
me last night making my chili like
thinking i'm martha stewart and then
when it tastes
like it's so disgusting like we all
emulate martha stewart in our kitchens
now we literally can
right marley's boom would never have
done that to you never so if you're
tired of cooking the same old same old
dinners
every day you can break out of making
yourself sick and you're tired of giving
yourself diarrhea every night
you can break out of your food rot with
martha stewart and marley spoon the meal
kit with chef design recipes from
america's most trusted home chef
martha stewart one of america's favorite
home chefs wants to make dinner for you
let her uh if you're tired of the same
old same old
and you're a morning toast listener you
can save a hundred dollars off your
first four orders and get free shipping
on the first delivery
use code toast that's code t-o-a-s-t
you can imagine eating deliciously
different chef quality meals every day
of the week
go to marleyspoon.com that's m-a-r-l-e-y
spoon dot com and the code is toast for
100 off your first four orders
and free shipping on the first delivery
check it out love it
okay first story the story that you want
to talk about most today
dogecoin spikes 300 in a week
stoking fears of a cryptocurrency bubble
but also very exciting for claudia
ashrae and all
doge owners okay i pulled up my um
we moved the business to the front today
okay so
i don't know what doji is i don't but a
lot of ben's friends work in finance and
they told us like a few weeks ago like
buy some dogecoin and in my robin hood i
have robin
but i really don't like it's not like
real like i don't put in a lot of money
just like
you know maybe in the last like two
years i made a thousand dollars so like
it's like small time you know and
i had two hundred dollars to spend on
like anything and they were like you
have to get dogecoin
so it was .04 so it was four cents when
i bought it
i spent the 200 and i've been like
checking it every now and then it was
like kind of like stagnant at 0.08 which
whatever like i doubled my money that's
great
but something happened last night like i
don't know i can't explain i don't even
know what dogecoin is and i can't
explain like
why it went up but last night and this
morning when i checked it was at .39 so
that's 39 cents when i bought it at four
cents
that is like
eight times okay no it's nine it's nine
it's nine times
it's nine so my two hundred dollars now
i'm looking at my robin hood
is worth they make it so confusing
fifteen hundred dollars
wow but i don't have the fifteen hundred
dollars should i sell it and get myself
my fifteen hundred dollars i don't know
i think we should go dogecoin to the
moon that's all i know about
dogecoin and i'm sorry 39 cents is not
the moon
no but they did say they think it could
get to a dollar like that would be crazy
and now i'm like you and also
i'm hitting myself you've got only
spending 200. you've got to ride the
ride that's part of
it it is like gambling you know you yeah
obviously you should get up from the
table when you're winning but i also
think gambling
is different because you keep putting
more money in whereas like this is you
have your set money
regardless of what happens you you are
losing or when like it's 200
and with gambling like the philosophy is
you really should not gamble money that
you don't have
so when you sit down on a gambling table
you are okay losing the money because
the like you're supposed to be able to
part with the money
but with stocks like these are people
savings like they're trying to grow it
so like this is money actually you
really can't afford to lose you know
most people this for me i just like put
like 500 in like a few years ago and
like i play around with it
yes but i feel like with gambling it
could become like a bottomless pit of
course you're trying to put your money
in whereas if sucks if you're like not
having success i don't think you have
that same like
it's not that same like adrenaline rush
of sitting at a table no and i think for
the moment like if you get all your
balance sheets back and they're all in
the red
they're not like give me more for the
most part and correct me if i'm wrong
like the stock market is a long game so
at the end of the day like
over the course of many years for the
most part every stock like pretty much
goes up like
eventually unless it goes down from the
rare case of like you know
franny mac you know yeah it's franny mac
no like we work yeah right like that was
like a once in a while but not every
stock goes up like
a lot of stocks go down because you
might like you just can't predict
the truth i just feel like overall like
with the main companies in the country
like everyone knows like obviously like
apple disney google
yeah for the most part like they just go
up yeah but they're also like super
expensive and like some weeks they dip
down
but for the most part yeah it's a long
game which is why you and your few weeks
of doge need to sit on your hands oh
yeah okay
and throw your phone but i could have 50
1000 oh no it's going down 1497. stop
looking
stop checking no but it's crazy that
it's gone up so much because it says
today's return so
since midnight of this morning i've been
already made 400 dollars but like i
don't
have the four hundred dollars you could
but that's the same with the stock
market like you don't have it yet until
you take it out
but like i want it so take it out no no
and then you and then because
it goes to a dollar and i'm the [ __ ]
who sold at 0.40 like i will
never recover like dave portnoy who's
like big and day trading like
got rid of josh coin a while ago and
like last night was tweeting like
because he was furious yeah
tripled no no it ate nine times like
yeah so i'm not gonna be that person
honestly i think i'd rather lose my two
hundred dollars than miss out on a huge
opportunity
a hundred percent and also i think it
just feels like i'm losing 1500
because i have like 1500 now technically
but i don't even have it
yeah but also with joshua considering
it's like started as sort of a joke like
it's literally a meme that was turned
into a cryptocurrency
you're in it for the experience you know
and honestly you want to be a part of
something
like i just want to be a part of a
community you're a part of something
with joshua
i'm part of a movement like a
generational movement like this will be
in like finance books
right and if you pull out like then also
that part goes into the finance book of
the people who pulled out no and i'm
also like
low-key influential so i feel like i
could actually like help the doge like
everyone like keep the doge
keep buying the doge dojo shows those
dozers
yeah okay well i'm really happy for you
no it's a thrill
and keep us posted i was talking one of
ben's friends
who like works in finance and like
invests a lot in stocks and he was like
i was asking him i'm like what do i do
and this is a few days ago he said i
made like the decision like if it ever
gets to point 30 which i could never
will
i'm gonna sell it and then like last
night he texted me he's like oh my god
never mind it's already at 0.35
and i'm like i wish i bought more he's
like yeah me too i only bought five
thousand dollars i'm like
what like i bought 200 like
i was embarrassed to even say i lied i
said i bought five
yeah you gotta you gotta risk it he was
like i'm so mad i didn't buy more i'm
like
you're fine okay so by my math my 200 to
1500
is seven times about so you have 35 000
and you're complaining wow if i was him
honestly
i might pull out big risk big reward
right
so i'm like man that only about 200 but
it makes it easier to like walk away
from in a sense
yeah i agree i think you're in a good
spot you do what's best for you you're
on your own journey
he's on his journey no like we're a part
of something together a hundred percent
i'm happy that you're a part of
something
you know me like i hate being left out
you hate being left out because you're
not like other girls so if i have to
lose 20 dollars
if i'm if i have to lose 200 just to not
be like other girls
cheap at the price okay
ready for our next story news man prince
phillips funeral
arrangements are being shared including
the guest list his funeral will be on
saturday
and it will be smaller than you know
what it would have been
but buckingham palace has revealed the
30 people who will make up the
congregation at the duke
of edinburgh's funeral service very good
um prince philip who died last friday at
the age of 99 is being laid to rest on
saturday at 3 p.m
british time 10 a.m eastern time at st
george's chapel in windsor west of
london
so the 30 people who are invited is a
very close group of family
close friend or two um but mostly
his children and their grandchildren i
mean like
coven makes it so tough because just
their immediate families like 15 people
yeah most of the guest list is the
princes and the dukes
of essex in wessex so like if it's
limited to like 30 people like do harry
and megan get into it well harry
harry is there i'm sure if megan had
wanted to go she has an invitation
because all of the spouses
are invited um and also the other bit of
news that was shared is the procession
and
harry and william will not be walking
next to each other they'll be like
william with someone and then
harry with someone yeah i also saw i was
reading something i forgot what it was
that like there's a lot of drama within
the family about
prince andrew and prince harry both
wanting to like wear their official like
military garb which they're no longer
eligible for one because andrew is a
disgrace who was stripped of like
all titles all titles and harry because
he's not technically like a working
military man or family or uh royal
family member yeah i think they should
both be wearing suits
yeah um it's just kind of crazy because
like whenever my
personal experience with funerals is
always like in judaism like you have to
bury someone the next day so like if
prince philip was jewish like he'd
already be in the ground like for like a
good amount of time
and i just like i think it's so crazy
that like he's like where is he
yeah no he's almost there it's actually
like where he's about chilling
i don't know westminster abbey the
hospital
hospital the freezer yeah
he's probably embalming yeah um
i just said that andrew and harry should
wear suits but i actually think that
prince philip would want them to wear
their i don't think he would want andrew
i don't know i think that i think he
would he's like i think that
like prince andrew is literally the
definition of an absolute abomination
disgrace like yeah
he shouldn't even be invited and to be
honest he should be excommunicated from
the entire country like he's so
disgusting like i can't even compare him
and harry like they're so different
they are so different like harry got
into a fight with his brother like
andrew is a full-blown criminal and i
don't think that he should be wearing
the garb and i don't even think he
should be invited
well we'll see what they're all wearing
i'm going to try and watch i've been
waking up so early these days
watch it um it'll be like on our morning
shows on saturday morning like a little
coverage
do you remember um that episode of the
simple life when they worked at a
funeral home and like we're embalming
people and like spray tanning them
that's so scary oh my god it was so
funny yeah such a good show
such a good show but that's i could
never no i could never
well actually i had dinner with phaedra
parks a few
months ago and i asked her like a
million questions she embalms
she owns a bunch of funeral homes and
she is a mortician is that the right
word
yeah um and so she knows all about
because she was explaining how like
there's so many different
like traditions for embalming jewish
people and like she's certified in all
of their religions
and i'm like aren't you like grossed out
and she was like no
i'm like that's okay like
perfect job for you crazy crazy
are you ready for our next story yes
ma'am pete davidson will play punk
rocker joey ramone in a new netflix
biopic
saturday night live comedian pete
davidson has been cast as ramon singer
joey ramon in the upcoming biopic based
on the punk icon's life oh my god
do you watch entourage sometimes like
i've seen some
a lot of episodes like do you know the
joey ramone of it all no that
i'm unfamiliar okay well like this is
like adrian greenway like was dying to
play joey ramon and he like found the
script from the sky he was writing it
and it was like a whole storyline
so now i feel like pete davidson is
literally living like vinnie chase
i literally hate vinnie chase so don't
hate
hey he's the literal carrie bradshaw of
that tragedy
he's horrible i hate him on the show
like i hate everything about him
i could not agree more and the show is
and then like mark wahlberg should be so
embarrassed
that like that's what people think of
him fictional representation
sick the worst [ __ ] character so
irresponsible
so selfish though righteous like he
literally thinks he's mother teresa
no because he has his friends with him
no no and he literally like acted in one
movie and then was like i want to direct
like
thought he was so [ __ ] good at
everything and when medellin bombed i
was so [ __ ] happy
yeah no he really thought he was so good
at it one art film in new york queens
boulevard and thinks he's entitled
to like all of hollywood yeah and oh my
god
but it actually was a really good show
for like a million reasons
but vinnie's efforts it was a good show
and also i think it was actually really
accurately represented like how people
get in hollywood like they
are normal people from new york from
queens and then they come to l.a like
thinking that they're
everything of the sort and like when
when it turns out that they're not
it's a real slap in the face yeah
because like there are a few moments
when like
vinnie like literally can't get work
because he's like such a joke in
hollywood
because people have woken up to have
woken up budgie [ __ ]
those are the best episodes like ever
except like you want vinnie to win
because once he wins everyone else wins
like
rising tides raise all ships like he
funds the life of
all the guys except for so like you
really want him to win but you also like
[ __ ] hate him and you just
you want him to fail so he can get a
reality check like you're not that great
a hundred percent i'm so glad you
brought that up it is the carrie
bradshaw susan meyer effect
yeah susan is annoying as hell but i
feel like desperate housewives is more
of an ensemble cast and it wasn't just
relying on susan but like
sex and city is carrie entourage is
annoying ass
agreed i wouldn't say that she's the
main character of desperate housewives
but it definitely felt like in the first
couple seasons they were trying to make
that make it that way yes she was
but like everyone else was like you know
gabby was like
self-involved brie was so like strange
luanne lynette scott
was like great like all over the place
like edie is like you know
seductive neighbor yeah and i think
susan was meant to be like you see
yourself in susan right like the normal
one who struggles
i'm good no no i see literally none of
myself and susan and i plan to keep it
that way
yeah anyways the film which is being
developed by netflix in
collaboration with xtx films will be
based on and have the same title as
ramone's brother
mickey lee's 2009 book i slept with joey
ramon a family memoir i guess that's a
funny name
that is really funny um i like don't
really know much about the hormones
except i feel like i used to have a
t-shirt
um and i'm down there i think they're
jewish right like from
um far rockaway right oh love to see it
or they have a song called rockaway
beach
one it's one or the other yeah you know
what i'm pretty sure they're jewish
um yeah let us know what you think
jewish i think the ramones were banned
yes
they were from forest hills queens that
is rockaway beach and a predominantly
jewish middle class stronghold that read
arrested this is not english oh man
rollingstone.com this is what they wrote
truckers for the ramones are here the
ramones oh they didn't share bloodlines
they were brothers but they did have an
important common background of coming
from an age
from coming of age in suburbia forest
hills queens a predominantly jewish
middle class stronghold
that bred a new and restively nest among
its non-conformist youth what is that
sentence
i have no idea let me read it one more
time let me read let me know
let me see if i need to see it with
grammar and what is the word
and new e-n-n-u-i n-u-i oh
no no but like i don't know what it
means
that makes no [ __ ] sense the ramones
didn't share bloodlines but they did
have the important common background of
coming of age in suburbia
in forest hills queens a predominantly
jewish middle class stronghold
that brother you can't even read a
predominantly jewish middle class
stronghold that bred nui and rustedly
nest
see it's literally not enough
what's a restively ness i don't know i'm
shook by this i just was looking up a
simple like interesting factoid
nui joey ramone was jewish
you guys also wait john was jewish i
just needed
davidson jewish no i need to sidebar for
one second speaking of the
french claudia's shirt yesterday which
sparked a whole francophile
episode about you know the louvre eiffel
tower
a shark board a little pony shock a lot
champ city stay claudia's shirt
yesterday
didn't had a bunch of buildings on it
the eiffel tower was not one of them
no there was literally like the burj
khalifa there was literally nothing
parisian about it
it said like night life on it it was
giving me parisian vibes for sure it was
giving me more like new york city like
bendel's
character vibes like there's nothing
parisian about that shirt yeah we just
wanted to update you guys like we made
all these jokes about my shirt being
like so parisian i'm i'm a club day in
peru
and literally there was not even a
monument from paris
on my shirt yeah so that's just
something i feel like everyone should
know
but now back to the ramones i'm looking
forward to seeing pete in something more
serious
and i'm looking forward to seeing the
the annuity that he brings to the table
and the rest of the nest
i feel like he'll be able to really
capture
the rest of things what is that what is
that word
i don't know that's not a word that's
just like by the way it's also
it was two separate words restively
which i don't think it's a word space
n-e-s-s what the [ __ ] um but i actually
would definitely see this movie
for sure and i think this could be pete
davidson's like big
yeah shift in his career from like stand
up
comedian and snl and like king of staten
island like that fun stuff to like
hard-hitting actor perhaps no it's like
kind of like what
um shallow hal did for jack black it is
kind of like that
that's such a good movie no it's like
steve carroll
yeah like you know when he started going
like really serious like dan
life of dan remember that movie no dan
i know no i don't even know a movie i'm
talking about marvin martian that one
the one with like oh no no that one
kristen wiig
yeah and that one was like little marvin
i'm honestly not a huge steve carell
girl clearly and also he was in
um crazy stupid love no but that was
when he was like transitioning into like
the more serious there was the movie
about
dan like right let's just go to his
catalogue there was also the movie
with billie jean king oh i have no idea
right
well not with her about her steve carell
dan in real life
okay oh it was a comedy drama welcome to
marwyn
that's when yeah yeah yeah okay battle
of the sexes is billie jean king one
he was in vice he was in the big short
amazing movie
he was in crazy stupid love
and unfortunately i think he was in
dinner for schmucks yes he was he was
literally the star and he was the most
annoying character
horrific he's in actually so many movies
but it's like going from 40 year old
virgin
you know he has actually had like a
really strong transitional career from
like silly comedy
to he's like a really serious actor now
like i don't know if he has been
nominated for an oscar but like it's
definitely in his future yeah so
i feel like that could be that's pete
davidson's future as well
interesting very good call next up
madison lacroix speaking out on a-rod
and j-lo's breakup and by speaking out
she said
five words the southern charm star told
page six on thursday when reached out
about the split
quote i wish them the best that's five
words
um okay honestly it's like not madison
lacroix's fault at all
no um but she's
enmeshed yeah which is crazy just like
in general like it's actually a great
moment for bravo
it is a great moment for bravo just
being a part of the narrative a part of
this big story this
big ship laying dormant in the south
china sea
laying dormant in the south china sea
also somebody had a good suggestion for
one of the ship's
new ship recommendations russell wilson
and sierra yes
and also haley and justin bieber yes and
yes i actually have like really big
ships i might be able to even fill
a jlo and a-rod with one of them yeah i
agree i feel like
we weren't able to think creatively no
but some people did give us good
suggestions
yeah and i feel good about kind of the
replacements
and best of luck to the boat sitting at
the bottom of the south china sea
best of luck dormant dormant are you
ready for our fifth and final story
it's the final story
dealing with what i think one of
my favorite topics that we've ever
discussed on
any of our shows and that is fire
festival
fire festival attendees win a seventy
two hundred dollar
settlement each in a two million dollar
class action
oh my god seventy two hundred dollars
they all have to split no no
seventy two hundred dollars each a two
million dollar class action lawsuit was
resettlement was
reached tuesday in u.s bankruptcy court
in the southern district of new york
between the festival's organizers and
277 ticket holders
according to documents obtained by
people the final amount is still subject
to the court's approval
though as it currently stands each
ticket holder would receive about
seventy two hundred dollars
and that's for like the price of their
flight tickets and just like general
torture trauma yeah okay like emotional
distress i think it's what it's called
in the legal system
yeah and like false advertising i mean
honestly seventy two hundred dollars
per person is not enough no if i had
actually went and like landed on this
remote island and was given a piece of
bread with a slab of cheese in like a
plastic container and given a tent to
live in when i paid for a villa
hell hatha no fury like those people
wish i was a part of this [ __ ]
lawsuit i would have taken them for
everything they have but at the same
time you're suing people who are
bankrupt so it's like
what's the point what's the point and
like the people
who went to fire festival like if you
watch the documentary like
they what were you doing you know one of
my biggest flexes is that i didn't fall
for
not saying that it was their fault
because it was advertised by like
fabulous people
but i just feel proud that like i wasn't
like you know
convinced by bella hadid to go to a
music festival he's done nothing
other than the fact that bella hadid
posted a video that had nothing to do
with it and like emily ratajkowski and
like kendall jenner like i actually feel
like really proud of myself because i
like to think of myself as like someone
who's easily persuaded
but like maybe i'm not because like the
coolest people in the world couldn't
convince me to go down to a fabulous
weekend in the bahamas
yeah and i don't even blame people who
did get convinced because they are very
convincing people
yeah but i'm just really proud of myself
not to make it about me
no i agree because it's something we
like could have went to it's true
i remember zach sent it to us and he's
like this looks cool when all like the
promo was coming out
yeah lazy yeah we're like yeah sure
whatever yeah
get the tickets like we'll go but just
like i'm not imagine imagine that we
had to blame zach
um so that's like a little bit of
justice
for the attendees we love to see it um
but i remember when watching the
documentary it's like the real justice
that needed to be served was for the
people of the island who gave like
resources
food labor towards especially just got
like taken advantage of and then the
island was left trashed
right so justice for the islanders
just as for the locals 100 yeah
well those are the fast five and i feel
as though you needed to know them no
very well-rounded we got finance we got
justice we got legislation like we got
it all
yeah we do have it all and that's what
you can expect from the morning toast
including
a recap of keeping up with the
kardashians yeah so what did you think
of the episode um i barely remember it i
when i came in this morning i was like
wait [ __ ] did i forget to watch
kardashians
no i watched it and shockingly the most
interesting part was push
yeah that push drama was like actually
pretty crazy and real
like felt very authentic it's very like
dash dolls
no it's like that's like the fact that
she was like having to like scold her
high school friend
like for talking back to her in a group
chat like drama
yeah no i can't lie the way that her
friend was sitting there in the bucket
hat and the sunglasses like with her
mouth a gape like
was so crazy imagine like showing up to
a meeting like that no totally and you
know what
i i can't lie you didn't watch i didn't
watch
i told you i was literally up all night
and i went to bed at 10 o'clock my
stomach was hurting me so bad for my
chili and the only thing i could do
to like ease my pain was go to sleep so
that's why i just like wanted to hear
from you what happened
okay not much happened so i would say
like that was the most interesting facet
like literally courtney needing to sit
down with her employees and be like
you guys are employees like we're not
this isn't like that's like hard this
isn't a democracy this is a chiropractor
that's like she said it the steph shep
of it all too like when you become so
close with your employees this is
different
she hired old friends she didn't become
friends with bless you
she hired two friends from high school
she didn't become close with an employee
no but even in general it doesn't matter
how like if you're close with your
employees like it does become awkward
when like you need to like lay the
gauntlet down yeah and
one of her friends from high school was
like talking back to her in the group
chat like
i'm this vibe isn't for me she literally
was like i'm just gonna excuse myself
from this vibe and left the chat
yeah it was really crazy so that was the
most interesting part i thought courtney
handled it really well
addison was in the episode i saw a tick
tock addison walked into the room while
courtney was complaining about the push
drama
and it said addison right dancer and
then she sat at the table and we didn't
even i don't even think she was mic'd up
i didn't hear a word okay it was so
upsetting that's so upsetting they
really need to start utilizing their
best assets it was an addison tease
then chloe and tristan put the episode
on their backs
because they went ufo hunters because
they went ufo hunting which was like
so stupid they literally had like a zoom
session with
that is so stupid so stupid but i do
they they thought they saw ufos but it
was kind of annoying
because like chloe they're like staking
out outside like trying to see a ufo
over the pacific ocean
and they see something and chloe like
runs on her phone and she misses it but
the camera got it
the the show so she was like i'm so mad
i didn't get to capture it
but you did go and not only did you
capture it not on your phone you got
like a full-blown
yeah no i i mean that's a dollar camera
yeah i saw what you saw like can you
just like that's cool
yeah and courtney was like why don't you
get a video like i want to see i'm like
watch the show keeping our literally
eight o'clock and it's in more high
definition than your phone could have
ever gotten
yeah so it's like so stupid it's so
stupid that like bugged me
and then caitlyn had reached out to
chris because her
career is kind of stalled because of
covid well actually sophia had reached
out to
chris on katelyn's behalf not stalled
because of cove but it's stalled because
like no well i guess
she's not that interesting anymore well
she had been doing motivational speaking
and like
speaking engagements and that is stalled
yes so
chris like suggested she make a youtube
channel and at first i was like oh she's
sabotaging
she doesn't want caitlyn to succeed um
but then they showed some clips of like
cooking with caitlyn and she was making
recipes from like chris's cookbook
and then the girls like like kim called
her and was like oh my god we
remember used to make that and i mean
i'm happy that they really are
all getting along so it seems like even
chris yeah and so the girls were like
we understand if chris doesn't want to
help her but
like i think in helping her it was like
um
beneficial for chris's process journey
yeah
yeah that's like always been like the
sad thing because like when they play
like old episodes of kardashians like
the first like five seasons on e all the
time
and you see how caitlyn was like such an
influential part of all the girls lives
and now it's like fast forward it's like
we don't even see caitlyn like ever
yeah so i really hope and of course
these things take time there is like a
brokenness there
but i do really hope one day like that
they can all get back on the same page
and it seems like this was a good like
this is a good part of that
journey for them so you didn't miss
anything i i won't even say you should
like watch it in order to watch the next
week
they really need to pick things up like
this is the final season you want people
to start watching your hulo show like
this
season not cutting it and then next
week's episode is like
courtney and scott talking about if they
should get married and like
like we know they're not he's dating a
12 year old he's hating a 12 year old
and she's part of kravis so let's move
on
and like you should have scrapped the
episode and throw it in the bin yeah
cause it's like the bin
because it's honestly embarrassing for
you guys yeah no i'm embarrassed
and i don't ship score like on any day
of the week
no i'm so old even if courtney's single
as a pringle and so is scott
i still don't ship they need two
different boats of course like for the
kids i think it would be great if they
got back together but they seem to
co-pair like so healthy like
maybe the best i've ever seen so i think
we should just leave that alone let
sleeping dogs lie
yeah the other thing that people were
talking about i saw in toast after dark
is like
chloe and tristan's like dynamic and
like they were like they have no
chemistry like
and i did get the vibe that like chloe
gets like really annoyed by him and like
you know what i mean but i also feel
like that's kind of part of like being
in a relationship is like
when your partner says something you're
like rolling your eyes you're like shut
up
but but he's really trying for the show
like
no that's what i was gonna say it's like
i don't think we can judge their
chemistry based off the show because
he's new to the show he's just like
acting
yeah like i don't think it's fair to
judge at all like
what their relationship and chemistry is
like because it's so awkward on the show
chloe's used to it like who chloe is on
the show i really believe it's like who
she is as a person but it's also like i
imagine i was thinking about this like
when the cameras turn on like
chloe gets into like cameras yeah and
like
sort of like how we do on the show like
but if you bring someone on who's never
done it before like you might get really
irritated by everything they say
maybe that's why we fight with our
husbands every time we do a podcast oh
i fight with ben every time we do a
podcast so that'll be us next week
oh how exciting great segway good luck
on your journey thank you we will all be
thinking of you
everyone have a great weekend reminder
monday through wednesday of next week we
are still back in the studio youtube and
podcast me and ben will be hosting
and then thursday friday of next week
there are no episodes so i just wanted
to remind you guys of that
jackie will be vlogging her entire
wellness experience on the patreon so
patreon.com
the morning toast also like i don't know
what the vibe is gonna be there you know
i might have to like bring a tripod to
like take some pictures oh that's
horrifying but assuming like
everything i i mean i might be like also
sharing a lot on my instagram i don't
know yet i'll have to see it you'll see
a weird meat like
taking selfies at the wellness retreat
like is that weird i don't know
we'll see just as long as someone's
looking and it's like if it's super
pretty i'm gonna like want to take some
pictures but like there's gonna be no
one there take a picture of me so just
know
if you see any photos of me like either
i did self-timer
or just keep that in mind or i made a
friend
probably self-timer thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the past life stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so
if you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so that's
spotify itunes stitcher public radio i
have already spoke to all the places
so every listener podcast find us
morning toast leave a five star review
about how beautiful sundang
i'm smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing weekend stay safe out there
don't drink and drive and we'll see you
on monday
goodbye goodbye
bye